what do you need from your Prime
Minister this morning what do you need
from David Cameron
well David Cameron I hope will spend
today as I will spend today campaigning
hard to persuade people right across the
UK to vote to remain within the European
Union and that's the outcome I want to
see from the referendum tomorrow because
it's right for our economy for jobs
we're part of the world's biggest single
market as part of the EU it's also
important for our freedom of movement
and travel I'm here right now at
Edinburgh Airport the capital city of
Scotland people can get on a plane and
travel anywhere in the European Union
freely we need to make sure we don't
give up that right and of course it's
also about a place in the world and I
think we should protect our reputation
as an outward-looking country that
cooperates with other countries across
Europe and the world all day I believe
country should be independent I'm a
Scottish nationalists but I also believe
independent countries in today's world
must work together for the greater good
to tackle all of these big challenges
like climate change and international
terrorism that no country can tackle
alone
First Minister how confident are you
that you will see a remain vote in
Scotland and very confident that we'll
see a remain vote in Scotland the polls
suggest that that will be the case and
but I'm taking nothing for granted I've
fought many campaigns and my payment
politics and I know that it's always a
mistake to take anybody's walk for
granted that's why I'm campaigning so
hard to make the positive case for
staying in the European Union so I I
hope that people tomorrow in Scotland
and across the UK will get out to the
polling station to protect our place in
Europe to protect the jobs that depend
on it protect the freedom of movement
that comes with the and to protect I
would have very little to play a part in
a bigger world from your campaigning
around Scotland what kind of reaction
will we see if the Scots vote remain and
England votes to leave well first of all
I very much hope that doesn't happen I
hope people in England Wales Northern
Ireland and Scotland vote to remain
but I've also said and said there's many
times before the Scotland faces the
prospect of being taken out of Europe
effectively against their will having
voted to remain then of course the
Scottish Parliament should have the
right to propose another independence
referendum but I hope that's not the
position within yes I hope Scotland
becomes independent in future but I hope
all of the UK chooses to stay in the
European Union because I believe it's
the better option for people regardless
of weed in the UK they live
First Minister I thought your March
quote was very very important here it is
folks this is the First Minister
speaking a few months ago before the
heat was turned up on this debate it is
not the Scottish National Party's policy
to seek entry to the euro now or at any
time in the foreseeable future it is not
our policy to seek entry to the euro now
or at any time I mean I look at this and
and I say First Minister the idea of
leaving Stirling and using the euro that
is a bold move do you need to begin that
debate on Friday
if leave wins no no no I I don't it's
not my policy to want to see Scotland
used the U door no order any time in the
future that actually was a court that I
gave no in March a old I may have given
it in March but I gave it as recently as
yesterday I want Scott to continue to
use the pound as we do just know what I
said just said he was all of these
debates about what happens is in the
event of a vote to leave the European
Union debates to happen after tomorrow
if we find ourselves in that situation I
don't want to be in that situation which
is why for the remainder of this
campaign I've tried to persuade as many
people as possible to get out tomorrow
and vote to protect our police in Europe
because our law depends on our place in
Europe